[Music]
welcome back
so i'm really excited today to tell you
about one of my absolute favorite topics
in fluid dynamics and dynamical systems
in general
which is how to extract these lagrangian
coherent structures from fluid flow data
specifically using the finite time
lyapunov exponent
so this is one of my absolute favorite
topics uh when you know one of the first
things i got interested in in fluid
mechanics
were these ftle fields and these
beautiful flow visualizations
of kind of unsteady flow structures
kind of analogous to invariant manifolds
from classical dynamical systems
so even back when i was an undergraduate
this really caught my attention
uh and i loved just looking at these
videos and kind of trying to understand
how flows evolved from
from from these coherent patterns and my
first projects
in graduate school were essentially on
how to compute these quantities
so i'm really excited today to walk you
through what these coherent structures
are
how we compute them using these finite
time leopon exponent fields
i'll give you plenty of examples of how
we use these to understand ocean
mixing how you know jellyfish eat
unstudy aerodynamic applications and
we'll talk about how to actually compute
these in practice
so this video i'm showing you right here
is essentially an airfoil
or a wing that's plunging up and down in
an
incoming flow so flows the fluid flow is
going from left to right
and this wing is plunging up and down
and these
lyapunov exponent fields that's
literally what's plotted in blue here is
the finite time lyapunov exponent
it's a quantity that you can plot in
space and time
and it shows when the flow is separating
when you get a large leading edge
separation
and it demarcates this rich wake
structure that's generated by this
airfoil
so you can use this to understand how
lift and drag are generated
for things like helicopter blades or a
fish swimming through
through the ocean and we've known for a
long time that there are these coherent
structures
that kind of emerge from complex fluid
flows
there's a wonderful book by milton van
dyke called an album of fluid motion
with
you know over 100 pages of beautiful
flow visualizations like this
that show the coherent structures in the
wake of objects
so this is a circular cylinder again
flow is going from left to right
and this is visualized using a classic
technique called smoke visualization
it's as simple as it sounds you take a
wind tunnel you put the circular
cylinder in the wind tunnel
and you put a stick of incense or a
cigarette or something else that
generates smoke
upstream and you see where that smoke
kind of accumulates
and outlines and highlights this rich
rich wake structure
which is known as a von carmen vortex
street
and so that's been used for decades this
smoke visualization to outline these
coherent structures
in the wake of fluid flows and the
finite time lyapunov exponent
is essentially a quantifiably rigorous
way
of doing that from data so we can
quantify
uh objects like these and how you know
how fast the smoke is accumulating and
things like that
from flow field data
i'll point out you know we have all
kinds of examples of coherent structures
in nature in technology that emerge in
these complex flow fields
so this is the atmospheric flow of
clouds over guadalupe island one of my
favorite
visualizations of coherent structures
and again you can see
very clearly just like the smoke
visualization this is a cloud
visualization where you can see the
the vortex street forming behind this
and so we would like a kind of rigorous
uh
way of numerically computing these
coherent structures from data like this
even in our art if you look at van gogh
or davinci
kind of our intuition of fluid flows is
centered around these coherent
patterns and coherent structures and so
we would also like it if the
patterns that pop out of this lagrangian
coherent structure analysis
were somehow consistent with our
intuition for what the essential
building blocks
of a flow field are things like vortex
you know cores
and sheer layers and things like that
and i really really like this image as
kind of a motivation so we're going to
get into the technical details in a
little bit
but i love this visualization from a
recent review paper by george haller
who is one of the pioneers of this field
of coherent structure extraction
i'll highlight this paper a little bit
later
but just to show that in you know lots
of exotic flows like the uh
atmospheric flow on jupiter you have
these persistent coherent structures
like the great red spot
or these you know very very rich sheer
layers
um and these lagrangian coherent
structures or lcs
give us a way of kind of quantifying or
demarcating different
regions of the flow that behave
differently or that are somehow
separated
from each other good
uh and this is just a teaser of some of
the applications i'll be talking about
so i'm going to talk about
unsteady aerodynamic applications things
like you know wind turbines or
wings moving we'll talk about how this
relates to mixing
in the ocean and even this really really
cool example of how a jellyfish feeds
understanding uh this feeding process
using these finite timely opponent of
exponents
okay so now it's time to dig into kind
of how these things are computed
what they mean more mathematically and
then we'll go back and revisit those
applications at the end
okay so i'm going to go back to this
flow field from the intro this is one of
my favorite visualizations i made during
my phd thesis
for uh kind of understanding plunging
motion at
a low flow velocity or over a small
scale wing
and what we're going to do here is
essentially in general we're thinking
about
the fluid flow as a dynamical system
uh given by this this right hand side
vector field u of
x and t so u is the unsteady fluid
vector field
this could be a vector of quantities u v
w
for the x y and z components of the
velocity if you have a three-dimensional
fluid flow
or this could be a two-dimensional
vector field if you have a 2d flow like
this one
and notice that this vector field so at
every point in space
x the flow points in a direction that
means that this is a vector field
and that vector field is unsteady
because it's changing
in time clearly you can see this movie
the vector field the fluid is changing
in time
and so what we're going to be thinking
about with these finite timely open of
exponents
is how do passive particles move along
this fluid velocity field
that's the thought experiment we're
going to be looking at so we're going to
consider the position of a particle x
so i'm going to drop a particle here
we're going to imagine that it's kind of
passive neutrally buoyant it just flows
along with the flow
and we're going to follow that particle
along the flow and see where it goes
and by looking at neighboring particles
and finding regions where those
particles separate the most
in forward time or in backward time
we're going to be able to highlight
these
very very cool kind of structures using
these
motions of passive particles and i'm
going to have you know a whole
lecture series on how to derive these
equations these kind of
fluid flow equations on the right hand
side how to think about passive
particles advecting along these
these fluid flows but for now you know
we're going to just kind of assume that
we know how to integrate particles along
those vector fields
so if you have an initial condition x
naught so some
particle position at time zero you can
essentially integrate its position along
this fluid velocity field to find out
where it will be at some later time
t x of t and the way they do
you would do that is essentially through
a numerical time stepping
scheme like a forward euler integration
or a runge-kutta integrator
you would take your initial condition x
naught you would compute the vector
field at that position at time knot
and based on that vector direction you
would step your particle
one delta t forward in time now at that
new time
there is a new velocity field this
velocity field has changed both in space
and in time because i'm at a new point
in space and a new point in time
and so now i use that new vector
direction and i take another step
and then at that point i take another
step and essentially you integrate along
this unsteady vector field
to get your position at a later time t
this is you know in math it's kind of a
complicated expression
if you have uh data for this vector
field or a function it's relatively easy
to integrate in matlab or python
using whatever numerical scheme you like
so we're going to call this the flow map
which essentially takes an initial
condition at time
0 and maps it forward to a final
position
at time t okay and we're going to denote
this by
big fee for the rest of this
presentation
good so what we're going to do now is
we're going to take
a grid of particles a whole uniform grid
of particles
we're going to map them all forward
through time we're going to integrate
all of them through this flow field and
we're going to try to find regions where
that stretches
the most that's going to highlight these
regions of large lyapunov exponent
lyapunov exponent is just a term from
classical dynamical systems that
quantifies
how much very very close particles
spread through a chaotic flow field in
time
okay so schematically that's what we're
doing we're taking a grid of initial
particles
we're mapping them forward through this
flow map and notice that they all get
kind of distorted and stretched out
and we're going to look specifically at
how neighboring particles
stretch and deform through this flow map
regions of high stretching and
deformation are going to be outlined as
bright bright blue
regions in this ftle field
really important and sometimes i forget
to say this this is super important
if you have this flow field you can
integrate particles
forward in time or you can integrate
particles
backward in time to see where they came
from both of those give you
important information about this
lyapunov exponent field
in fact these blue regions here that i'm
highlighting i actually
computed these by taking my grid of
particles and integrating them backwards
in time
so particles that stretch a lot in
backwards time
tend to be accumulating material in
forward time
that's what smoke visualizations do they
take smoke and they accumulate that
smoke into
these very very thin wake lines so to
get the equivalent of
smoke visualization movies that are very
intuitive to us humans
you actually take your grid of particles
and integrate them backward in time
so i'm going to talk about both of these
integrating particles forward in time
and integrating particles backward in
time to find out where
neighboring particles stretch the most
in forward or in backward time
and the reason i care about regions that
stretch the most in forward and backward
time is because that gives us a direct
analog
of unsteady and steady manifolds but for
these time varying vector fields
good stable and unstable manifolds for
these time varying vector fields
and so that's what i'm showing here
again this is the flow field for a fixed
wing at a
constant angle of attack fluid is going
from left to right
and here i'm integrating particles
forward in time
here i'm integrating particles backward
in time
and you can see these two kind of ftle
sets here
that are illuminating kind of different
regions of the flow field
and and this is a really interesting
point oftentimes
these finite time leaping of exponents
have
really really high values or ridges kind
of mountain ridges
in the flow field that's what i'm
visualizing here in red and in green
and you'll notice that particles that
start inside this red
region stay inside particles that
started outside kind of whizzed by and
stayed outside
and so these red ftle ridges
are almost like invariant manifolds
where the particles can't pass through
them
so particles that stay on one side of
this invariant manifold
that start there stay there and
particles that start
outside will also stay outside
similar for the reverse time structures
and so that gives us a direct analog of
these stable
and unstable manifolds for uh
for the classic dynamical systems that
don't vary in time
okay and stable and unstable manifolds
is one of the most important ways that
we understand
non-linear differential equations so if
you have a nonlinear differential
equation like this
you might look for the fixed points
linearize about the fixed points
to find some eigenvalues and
eigenvectors so you might see if it's a
stable fixed point or a saddle point
and then you would take the eigenvectors
associated with those eigenvalues
and those will essentially give you
subspaces where the dynamics are
invariant and if you continue along
those subspaces
you'll sweep out these manifolds where
if you start on one side of the manifold
you stay on that side forever
which is really really useful it's a way
of kind of segmenting
your your phase space uh into different
coherent regions
and the finite timely opponent exponent
calculation
gives you a direct time varying analog
of these stable and unstable manifolds
but for unsteady flow fields
so it's really useful in carrying all of
our intuition from dynamical systems
over to these time varying fluid systems
and that's why
people love to use these so much because
there's a ton of intuition we have
from classic dynamical systems theory
and again here i'm going to talk more
about these papers later but these are
kind of the two main papers i think of
when i think of lagrangian coherent
structures and finite timely open up
exponents related to manifolds
good now it's a little uh maybe
counter-intuitive
why the unstable manifold in red
that's where you know if i started a
little bit to the left or right of my
fixed point i would go out forever
why do those attract particles in
forward time
right it sounds like they should be
repelling particles forward time it's a
little counterintuitive
but the way i want to think about this
is if i have two particles
kind of on the left side of this green
stable manifold
at up and down right where my hands are
in forward time the stable manifold is
going to push them towards the unstable
manifold
and then along the unstable manifold so
you can actually picture
that particles do tend to get closer and
accumulate onto the unstable manifold
they almost
shrink wrap onto the unstable manifold
in forward time
and so that's why i painted these
structures here red these forward time
attracting structures
are essentially analogs of the unstable
manifold because particles or smoke
visualization smoke
will accumulate onto these red ridges in
forward time
and similarly these backward time
structures are analogous to my stable
manifold
these are points that kind of diverge in
forward time
or collect particles in backward time
if i reverse time my unstable manifold
would become stable
and my stable manifold would become
unstable good
and i cooked up this little
visualization to kind of show what i
mean here so again this is just a saddle
point a classic saddle point
the green are my kind of
stable manifold the red is my unstable
manifold
and if i have these little kind of blobs
of fluid
here and i i kind of march them
backward in time you see that if i
reverse
time they squash along these
uh this stable manifold this green
manifold
and so that's actually what i would do
i'm going to restart this visualization
so what i actually do to compute this
this red manifold or this green manifold
is i take a bunch of particles
i integrate them let's say backward in
time so
remember arrows are going this way so if
i integrate them backward in time things
go the other way and i try to find
regions where they stretch the most in
backward time
that will illustrate these these red
lines
so for example things along this red
manifold
will stretch the most in forward time
as they stretch along this the screen
manifold
now this is a little bit of a kind of
tricky concept to wrap your head around
you'll have to really think about where
particle goes in forward time
and in backward time to convince
yourself of how of like which direction
you should integrate to compute the red
and the green structures
now you can do that and kind of overlay
these for
this this uh airfoil example i was
showing you earlier
and you see that there's this kind of
time-varying set of unstable manifolds
that determines all of the fluid
transport in this
uh in the system and i want to point out
again
saddle points from dynamical systems are
super important for understanding how
energy efficient transport happens so
for example i am an inverted pendulum or
an inverted double pendulum
which has one or two saddle points and i
use the
unstable direction of that saddle point
when i want to walk
forward efficiently i kick myself in the
unstable direction
the instability carries me almost for
free energetically
and that's how humans walk that's how we
design efficient space missions to
jupiter
and that's how if we were for example
traversing the ocean
we might use these time varying saddle
points
to to jump on one side and get carried
away by the unstable manifold
so these this idea of an unstable saddle
is super important
for these time varying systems
okay good um so now i'm going to go into
a little bit of the history
talk a little bit more about nuts and
bolts of computation and then give some
examples
this entire idea of these lagrangian
coherent structures and how to use these
finite timely app and have exponents
came out of this seminal paper
by george haller in 2002 it's a
fantastic paper
so i highly recommend you you read it
where essentially he
showed how you would compute these kind
of objective
lagrangian coherent structures from
velocity field data if you had data from
a system how would you compute where
these invariant manifolds are and and we
say lagrangian
because the traditional methods
essentially just looked for
regions of high vorticity or things like
that like you know
tornado cores in your flow but if those
were moving along
in a time varying fashion those
techniques didn't work very well
and this is more robust one of the
things that was really important about
this paper
is that essentially he showed
you could apply this to noisy vector
field measurements from experiments
even if you had some outliers or some
bad measurements or some noise on top of
your velocity field
you would still get robust estimates of
these coherent structures
because they're somehow persistent and
because you're integrating particles
through them
and that generally smooths over a lot of
numerical
inaccuracies in your flow field so
really good paper kind of the leading
paper
starting this all off another one i
really used a lot when i was getting to
know finite time we open of exponents is
this great paper by
shannon leckian and marsden where they
essentially showed how to compute
these things they gave lots of examples
um
they talked about how these lagrangian
coherent structures or those
ridges of finite timely append of
exponent
are material lines they're kind of these
barriers or these
unsteady invariant manifold analogs
and they computed these using data uh
you know in real physical flows like
this is the flow
off of the coast of florida and they
computed these separators
where if you were on one side if you
dumped you know
whatever something here it would stay
here for a long time
whereas if you you know released
particles here they might flow out to
the ocean
really important paper these are kind of
the two big ones
and then recently george haller wrote
this fantastic review paper in the
annual review of fluid mechanics
on lagrangian coherent structures i
highly recommend you read this it's got
some of the best visualizations
and descriptions it's one of the the
best annual reviews i've read
and again it talks about how there are
these kinds of analogs to classical
dynamical systems
you know chaos and kam theory
but for these time varying fluid flows
using these lcs
okay so really important stuff here
if you're interested in kind of reading
about the history of these things
now i want to tell you about how to
compute these things at the end of the
day i
you know love numerix i love actually
computing things from data
and a lot of my career has been focused
on how do you actually compute these
finite time liability of exponent fields
quickly efficiently accurately from data
so i'm going to walk you through the
steps and then we'll talk about what
they mean
and how to interpret it okay so if you
have some fluid flow in my case i'm
always thinking about these air foils at
low reynolds numbers and
some big angle of attack that's given by
this little white line here
what you're going to do is you're going
to drop a grid of particles
a uniform grid of particles that covers
the area you're interested in
and you're going to integrate that set
of particles forward in time or backward
in time
using this flow map that we talked about
earlier so that's essentially step one
initialize the grid of particles flow
them all forward in time or backward in
time
and now what you're going to do is for
every single point in that grid i've
zoomed in on this little white point
here
you're going to look at that point and
its nearest neighbors
and you're going to see how those
nearest neighbors got deformed after
that flow map
okay and in general this is just a
cartoon but in general what you're going
to have is you're going to have some
directions where they stretch a lot
some directions they might contract and
they might also rotate
and for an incompressible fluid flow
kind of the area
of this diamond should be the same as
the area
of the deformed diamond okay that's for
an incompressible fluid flow that's kind
of an idealized case
but the area should be preserved before
and after this mapping
it's a good numerical check you can do
when you're computing these things so
okay at every single point in this grid
there is some
deformed set of neighbors they tilt and
stretch
and so what i'm going to do is i'm going
to compute an approximate
jacobian or derivative of that flow map
with respect to delta x and delta y
okay so i'm going to walk you through
this this is a little bit hairy but what
we're doing here
is we're approximating the derivative of
that flow map or the sensitivity of that
flow map to small perturbations
by literally computing the finite
delta x okay so this first term here is
delta x
at final time divided by delta x at
initial time so i literally compute
this delta x between these blue points
divided by the initial delta x between
these blue points
that's the first element here then i
compute the delta y
of these final points divided by the
delta x of those initial points
okay that's the second term this first
red term
is the delta x of these red points
so the kind of x spacing between them
with respect to the
delta y of these two red points and then
this final term here
is the y difference between these two
red points this delta y
divided by the initial delta y what this
is this is like the crudest
finite difference derivative
approximation of the partial
of the first component of the flow map
with respect to x the partial of the
second component of the flow map with
respect to
the first component with respect to y
the partial of the second component of
the flow map with respect to x
and the partial of the second component
of the flow map with respect to y
bit of a mouthful even worse in three
dimensions but you get the idea i'm
basically taking these
grid of particles this data i'm
integrating them forward and i'm
approximating the finite difference
partial derivatives using these deltas
these finite width deltas
and this is uh that whole ugly
expression written in coordinates in
case you're a masochist
you can compute this thing for every
single point
all of these white points i can compute
this little matrix okay
and this matrix of jacobian
derivatives is going to be different at
every point here
if i have a lot of stretching and
deformation
at one point i'm going to have a
jacobian that that
exhibits a lot of stretching in that
component
and so the eigenvectors and eigenvalues
of this jacobian of the flow map is
basically going to tell me
along what directions am i stretching
the most or contracting the most
and by how much again for incompressible
fluid flows
this should have a determinant of one or
approximately one
numerically good
okay so the last step is so we float all
these particles forward
now we've computed uh the flow map
jacobian at every point this is an
expensive computation because i might be
doing this at 100 000 points
now at every single one of those points
i take
the largest eigenvalue of
this matrix times its transpose
now you could just take the largest
singular value
of this matrix that's the same exact
thing so the maximum
singular value of this uh jacobian
flowmap jacobian basically says what is
the maximum amount i could possibly
stretch
from this particle if i moved epsilon
away from it
so if i was at this particle and i moved
a teeny little epsilon in any direction
where would i stretch the most what
would be the maximum stretching i could
get
that's given by this lambda max of this
delta quantity here or the maximum
singular value of this flowmap jacobian
and the last step is that you take the
logarithm of the square root of that
and divide by the integration time big t
these are basically just
scaling it so that you can plot them and
they look nice
but really it's this quantity here this
lambda max that you care about
okay and i realized i'm missing uh right
parentheses here so we can just pretend
that it's there
okay let's take a big step back and
summarize here so
at every single particle we've
integrated it forward in time
computed a finite difference derivative
matrix to see how much that
that neighbors are stretching at that
point
and we pick the maximum amount of
stretching that could occur
and that is this value sigma the finite
time we have on an exponent
and there is a value of sigma for every
single
point on this grid that's why it looks
like a
flow field is because there's a finite
timely open of exponent value at every
single point in space
it gets worse because that was just one
snapshot of a movie
the next frame in the movie i have to
reinitialize this grid
reintegrate all of those particles
forward recompute all of these
quantities and that's the finite time we
happen of exponent at the next time step
of the movie
and the next time step i have to do it
again and again and again
so this is an extremely expensive
computation
to integrate all of these particles
starting from every initial time
step of your movie forward in time and
computing all of these quantities
but if you can do this this finite time
liability of exponent field will tell
you
where in space will i get the most
stretching forward in time
that's a very useful quantity again
because it tells you
what what regions are analogous to these
stable and unstable manifolds
and let me see if i can get this right
if i wanted to compute the
stable manifolds which repel particles
in forward time
i would integrate particles in forward
time and find the maximum stretching
if i wanted to find the unstable
manifold those red manifolds that
attract particles in forward time
i would actually integrate my particles
backward in time and find the largest
backward time
ftle because again if they stretch a lot
in backward time
they attract a lot in forward time makes
a lot of sense
okay good this is the one slide overview
of how to compute ftle
i'm going to make more videos where we
actually code this up in matlab and
python
for some examples i'll also tell you in
future videos about how you can
massively speed this up by removing
redundant calculations that was kind of
the first paper i ever wrote
was in speeding this up when you're
computing this for a movie
of ftle fields good
okay and going back to this picture here
now i think we're finally ready to
really understand
uh what these mean so the red
ridges these are values of largest
finite timely app on of exponent
there are other values but i'm plotting
this on a log scale so only the biggest
values show up in red
and these are finite time weapon of
exponents that i actually computed by
integrating particles backward in time
so these red ridges diverge the most in
backward time
which means that they actually show how
particles converge in forward time they
give me this
kind of smoke visualization coherent
structures that i want
and again they are analogous to these
manifolds that separate particles if you
start on the outside you stay on the
outside
if you start on the inside you stay on
the inside
similarly these green uh manifolds here
these green
finite timeline of exponents are
computed by integrating particles
forward in time and finding where they
stretch the most
and that gives me this stable manifold
that
again attracts if you integrate in
backward time
good and uh our analog here
so one of the cool things about this is
that this applies equally well to data
from
experiments from particle image
velocimetry measurements you can
literally shine a laser sheet in your
wind tunnel with uh
some you know neutrally buoyant
illuminated particles
and you can use those vector fields to
compute these coherent structures
you can also compute them from the
vector fields you get from direct
numerical simulations from big
computer simulations which is where i
spent most of my time
and now i'm just going to walk you
through some of my favorite examples of
of these quantities so this is one of my
favorite papers by melissa green clancy
rowley and george howler
where they showed that you could apply
this to full three-dimensional flow
fields turbulent flows
uh in this case in this channel flow
they showed that you get these
really really cool uh what are called
hairpin head vortices
they kind of look like little mushroom
head vortices that are climbing out of
the boundary layer wall
and they showed that this uh this
channel flow is kind of riddled with
these hairpin
vortices that are really nicely outlined
and isolated kind of
uh extracted using these lagrangian
coherent structures
another one i really like this is from
that review paper by george haller
but taken from this prl paper originally
where they had kind of a table top
experiment a circular dish
that was being excited to exhibit
turbulence
and you can see that these lagrangian
coherent structures the forward and
backward time the repelling and
attracting lcs
outline this incredible template for how
mixing occurs in this turbulent fluid
and again if i wanted you know if this
was a model of the ocean and i wanted to
get from point a to point b
i would probably try to use the saddle
points
and try to navigate these saddle points
for energy efficient transport
and i'll try to put a link to a video by
my phd student karthik krishna
who is using kind of these coherent
structures for
optimal navigation in ocean flows
good okay so a few more applications
that are near and dear to my heart again
we've already talked about these
unsteady
fluid dynamic applications where you
have airfoils pitching and plunging
again this is a lot like what the blades
of a helicopter do
as they are going around in a circle
they pitch up when they're advancing
i'm sorry they pitch down when they're
advancing and up when they're retreating
to balance the loads and so this gives
us a lot of understanding of how those
separated structures and wake structures
might impact the lift and the drag
i generated these from numerical
simulations from
codes by tyra and colonias
and you can do things like look at the
actual forces on these objects as these
flow fields are evolving you can look at
the lift and the drag forces
kind of as different vortices are being
formed and shed
uh on these these wing structures and so
you know i've spent
hours and hours looking at these trying
to understand how could we model
these lift and drag forces by you know
the coherent structures being generated
in the wake
okay you can also use this to understand
real devices like
uh wind turbines you know vertical axis
wind turbines
if you knock them over in the water
they're called cross flow turbines
this is work with ben strom who is a phd
student formerly with brian pelagi and
myself
and this is a laboratory expel
experiment in brian's lab
where we have a two-bladed turbine in a
water channel
and we were doing control experiments to
try to increase the power output
of this turbine and so from flow
visualization
like this you can essentially extract
these lagrangian coherent structures
and get a lot of rich information about
how the flow field evolves
what are the the stable and unstable
manifold structures
for example you see this beautiful shear
layer structure
on the uh being shed from the upper
blade and this more classic
wake kind of structure from the lower
blade
and at different turbine parameters
these might interact
in different ways so very very useful to
get a more holistic picture of the
structures being generated
by your your turbine
and this is especially important if we
want to put
a downstream turbine in the wake and try
to harness some of these structures
so what we really want to do is we want
to have an array of these cross flow
turbines or these vertical axis turbines
and we want to understand where would we
putt them to optimally exploit
these coherent structures in the wake
good okay um
this is absolutely my favorite video
whenever i talk about lagrangian
coherent structures
in my class i always show this video um
it blew me away so this is how jellyfish
eat a paper by
shaden de beery and marsden 2006 you
have to read this
and essentially what they did was they
estimated the flow field
around this jellyfish and there have
been subsequent experiments
where you know they actually have an
underwater piv laser
to collect measurements of this it's
very kind of high tech cool stuff
and what they do is based on that
velocity field
they compute if i was a passive particle
where would i
end up getting integrated along the
vector field of the jellyfish
so this jellyfish is moving its its uh
i guess tail area here to create a
propulsive wake
and what's really interesting is as it
creates its propulsive wake it actually
is entraining
material into its inner bell where it
digests
and so you can see this red lagrangian
coherent structure here
very clearly outlines regions where if
you start on one side you stay on that
side so a blue region stays blue
but eventually this blue packet is going
to get entrained
or sorry this one's going to get ejected
but the green packet here is going to
actually get entrained
into the wake into the inner bell region
so i just love this video because it
shows kind of simultaneously how a
jellyfish is creating a propulsive wake
by blowing all of this blue momentum
out from it and it's also entraining
fluid into its bell
so it's swimming and eating at the same
time and that's made very very clear by
these finite timely opponent exponents
uh this is another kind of really cool
extension
where dabiri and parker essentially use
these ideas to create this robotic
jellyfish
so this is an actual i believe heart
tissue from a rat
with these little pacemaker cells on
this octagon
and they put this in an electrolyte
solution that they can pulse
and essentially they can create this
pulsing muscle
motion you'll see it in a moment that
mimics
yeah this external pacing when they turn
it on it's going to mimic
the motion of that jellyfish
again you know you can kind of
understand this by those coherent
structures
how it would actually propel itself just
beautiful work
really really cool stuff
um one of the areas that this has been
applied to the most
is in understanding mixing so this
is a flat plate airfoil that's moving up
and down
in a still fluid just kind of mixing it
up and you can see these attracting
lagrangian coherent structures these
attracting ridges of finite timely
apparent of exponent
are essentially demarcating these
regions of mixing
in this flow field and i'll i'll point
out when i say lagrangian coherent
structure i usually mean
a ridge of this finite timely appointed
exponent field
so this is the original vorticity field
just how much it's it's
locally swirling this is the attracting
finite time layout of exponent we obtain
this by integrating particles backward
in time
and this is the repelling set we obtain
by integrating particles forward in time
and you see that the kind of ftle fields
give you a lot
of additional information that you might
not get just from this vorticity field
so for example at two different phases
of
of this plate going up and down you can
see that there are these very distinct
regions a b and c that demarcate
kind of different packets of fluid that
will stay coherent
at least for one period of plunging
oscillation
and similarly you can see fluid that
will about to be entrained
or about to be entrained into the left
vortex or the right vortex
and if you start following these
particles around kind of like in that
jellyfish movie
you can start getting a lot of insight
into how the mixing is occurring in
these flows
okay good this has been applied a ton
to understand mixing in the ocean
unfortunately a lot of our
study of unsteady dynamical systems
comes from understanding where pollution
goes in the ocean it's really kind of a
human tragedy that
so much of our time is spent thinking
about where to dump stuff or
oops we dump stuff where is it going to
go so for example in monterey bay there
are these very strong material lines
where
if you dumped stuff on one side it would
just recirculate in the bay for a long
time
whereas if you dumped it on the other
side it would get ejected out into the
ocean
and mix better similarly you can
understand for example the gulf of
mexico oil spill
using these kinds of coherent structures
so
whether or not it's a good or a bad
thing it's quite interesting
that you can understand a lot about
mixing and transport in the ocean
using these lagrangian coherent
structures
uh and this is a picture that philip
dutois made when he was a phd student
with jerry marsden i love this this
picture
that shows kind of this full global
scale lagrangian coherent structure
computation
so you can see just all these rich rich
patterns uh
in the kind of you know earth weather
systems
very cool stuff okay good and
i think i mentioned that you compute
these quantities
these these lagrangian coherent
structures as the ridges
of finite time weapon of exponents
one piece i really want to point out
here that i think is super important
is that these finite time lyapunov
exponent fields
tell you a lot about where your flow is
the most sensitive to perturbations
and this is super important if you are
interested in control theory
so you know again we're going to be
looking at this analog of an unstable
saddle point
where you know particles kind of flow
from one
uh one manifold to the other in forward
or backward time
and so if i have uh some position x
where i'm at in my flow field
and i add a perturbation to it you can
essentially tailor expand how that
particle will flow forward in time
and the perturbed particle will be near
the original particle
at some later time t plus this
amplification factor
and this amplification is given by the
flow map jacobian
dotted with this perturbation epsilon
and this is going to be
largest at regions where the finite time
the open of exponents largest
so where the ftle field is the biggest
is where you have the most opportunity
to affect your flow
with small perturbations so i've heard
melissa green say this before
that these ftle ridges are kind of where
if you put order epsilon energy in
you can get order one out after some
finite time
and that can be really really useful for
uh
this is also a very useful expression
for numerical analysis just to analyze
what happens in these flow fields
these these taylor expansions can be
quite useful
okay um parting thought the way that we
computed these lagrangian coherent
structures 10 years ago
was we would compute a finite timely app
on our exponent field like i showed you
we would take the logarithm and there
would be ridges
and then we would act actually compute
the ridges of that ftle field using some
kind of a ridge tracking algorithm
you'd look for places where there's you
know
zero derivative and highest curvature
and you basically pull out the ridges of
the ftle field
and that would be the lagrangian
coherent structures
recently this paper by mohamed farizman
and george haller
showed that there is a better way of
computing those lagrangian coherent
structure
ridges from your ftle field using a
variational theory
so this will take a little bit too much
time for me to unpack here
maybe i'll do a video on this in the
future but if you're really serious
about computing these ridges
this is the algorithm you want to use
again still based on the finite timely
append of exponent
but just a better way of computing these
lagrangian coherent structures
from those ridges uh some important
things
i like didn't really have too much time
to get into there's there's
this could literally be like a whole
class on lagrangian coherent structures
is that these ridges of ftle these
values of high
stretching highly append exponent
sometimes that stretching of particles
occurs because the particles are
stretching perpendicular to these
blue ridges sometimes the stretching is
happening because of shear
roll-up and technically the lagrangian
coherent structures you want
are the ones that are perpendicularly
shedding or kind of
normally hyperbolically shedding those
are the ones that give you kind of the
analog of these stable and unstable
manifolds
okay so there will be more videos about
how to compute these things how to code
these up
how to do it more efficiently for movies
like this one
maybe we'll dig into kind of how that
sensitivity analysis
looks uh for real flow fields and how
you would use this for control theory
all right thank you
you